Çeviri: Mehmet Bingül
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Merhabalar, ben Rick Köletavitoğlu.
Yaklaşık beş senedir Türkiye'deki
girişimcilik ekosisteminde çalışmaktayım.
Ve birçok kez 'Fuck up' ettim.
Şimdi, hayata başlarken
bir rol seçmeniz gerekecektir.
Bunu bir film yapımına benzetebiliriz.
Filmde bir yapımcı vardır.
Bir yönetmen, bir yıldız oyuncu
ve bir de yıldız oyuncunun asistanı.
Yapımcı kararları verir, senaryoyu seçer.
Yönetmen ise kararlar verir,
oyuncuları seçer
ve yaratılan işin
kalitesini belirler ve korur.
Yıldız oyuncu ise
selfie çekmek istediğimiz insan.
Ünlü olan.
Onu da yönetmen seçer.
Bir de onun asistanı vardır.
Asistan ise gün içerisinde
kahveleri taşır, fotokopileri çeker
ve durmadan bir şeyle uğraşır.
Onun da istikrarlı bir maaşı vardır,
ve starın yanında,
yakınında olmanın memnuniyeti...
Liselilerle yapılan bir araştırmaya göre
bir CEO ya da yargıç olmaktansa
bir starın asistanı olmayı
tercih etmişler.
Yıldızın yanında emniyette...
Ben bu rollerin hepsini oynadım
ve siz de hayatınızın farklı anlarında
ve durumlarında oynayabilirsiniz.
Ama benim size söyleyeceğim şey
güven mi yoksa cesaret mi?
O yıldızın yanında durarak mutlu olmak
kolay. O yıldıza tapmak daha da kolay.
Asıl mesele o kararları vermek,
o kararları verecek cesareti
göstermek ve onun arkasında durmak.
Cesaret mi yoksa güven mi?
Kişisel cesaret gösterdiğiniz zaman
bazı riskler almamız gerekiyor.
Bunun kötü sonuçları da olabilir,
iyi sonuçları da olabilir.
Ama bir şey biliyorum ki burada
bir büyüme sağlanacaktır.
Düşseniz de yeniden ayağa kalkarsınız.
Burada göstereceğiniz cesaret sizi
bir şekilde geliştirecektir.
Steve Jobs.
30 yaşında kurduğu firmada, inandığı
bazı ilkeleri savunduğu için atıldı.
Sonradan da yalvarılarak
geri getirildi firmaya.
Ve şimdi de Apple
dünyanın en değerli firması.
Walt Disney.
Aranızda Disneyland'e giden var mı hiç?
Bir el görebilir miyim?
Süper.
Walt Disney, çalıştığı gazete firmasından
yaratıcılığı kısıtlı diye atıldı.
Ve bu, bize Mickie Mouse'u veren insan.
Lionel Messi.
11 yaşında hormon eksikliği yüzünden
futbol takımına alınmadı.
Ve günümüzün en başarılı futbol oyuncusu.
Michael Jordan.
Lisedeyken basketbol takımına alınmadı,
eve gitti, kendini bir klozete kapadı
ve hüngür hüngür ağladı.
6 kez NBA şampiyonluğu yaşamış, 5 kez de
en değerli oyuncu seçilmiş:Michael Jordan.
Marshall Mathers.
Liseden terk.
Uyuşturucu bağımlılığıyla boğuşurken,
neredeyse hayatına son verdi.
Şimdi ise hiphop dünyasının
bir numarası olarak görülen,
100 milyon albümden fazla satan,
sahne ismiyle: Eminem.
Başarısızlık ya da girişimcilik
hayat boyu devam eden bir şeydir.
Vasat olabilirsiniz bu dönemlerde.
Düşürüp düşebilirsiniz.
Ama asıl mesele kendinizi,
yeniden ayağa kaldırmak
ve devam etme cesaretini gösterebilmek.
FuckUp Nights, 2012'de Mexico'da kurulan
bir organizasyon.
Şimdi de 150 şehirden fazla yerde etkin.
Ayda bir kere on binlerce insanın
başarısızlık hikayelerini paylaşarak
girişimciliği cesaretlendirmek
amacıyla kurulan bir hareket.
Biz de İstanbul ayağını başlattık
ve birinci senemizi doldurmak üzereyiz.
Biz bunu neden yapıyoruz?
Çünkü bu fikirleri paylaşmak istiyoruz.
Biliyoruz ki insan hayatında onlarca
kez düşüp yeniden kalkabiliyoruz.
Cesaretimiz gerekiyor. Devam edeceğiz.
Son olarak sizi Aristo'nun
bir sözüyle bırakmak istiyorum.
Aristo demiş ki:
Cesaret ilk erdemdir.
Cesaret ilk erdemdir ki
bütün öbür erdemleri olası kılar.
Her gün sabah kalkabilmek için
cesarete ihtiyacımız vardır.
Kalkıp kahvaltımızı yapıp dişlerimizi
fırçalamak için cesarete ihtiyacımız var.
Servise binip okula gelmek için
cesarete ihtiyacımız vardır.
Bu cesaretimizi zaman zaman kaybedebiliriz
ama ayağa kalkıp yeniden
devam edecek cesareti gösterebilirsek
o zaman yolumuza devam edebiliriz.
Çok teşekkür ederim zamanınız için.